معناها من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس حنا كيف
تنظر الى تطويق بخموت واهميه السيلاء قوات
فاجنر على هذه البلده بلده براسك
سلمى هي بلده من ضمن بلدات محيطه
بمدينه بخموت هي مرحله الاستراتيجيه او
التكتيك المتدرج يعني نبدا بالتتويق من
الشمال ومن الجنوب للوصول الى النموذج
الروسي والذي يقول بالانجليزيه او المرجل
يعني تطويق المدينه نصب المدافع وبالتالي
العمل على تدميرها وبالتالي يعني اصبحت
مخموت مدمره هذه المدينه هي جزء من مسرح
اكبر ولكن نتحدث عن محمود بعد سبعه اشهر
او اكثر من سته اشهر لم تسقط فكيف عن كل
اقليم الدومباس حيث قال
ان للسيطره على كل اقليم الدمباز يستلزم
القوات الروسيه وحتى فاجنر ما يقارب السنه
او السنتين
اذا بالتالي
وطبقا لعمليه التعبئه التي جرت في روسيا
وايضا ادخال ميليشي وايضا عمليات التسليح
من مصادر مختلفه وبمقابلها الطرف الغربي
الذي يزود اوكرانيا بالمزيد من المعدات
كيف تنظر الى توازي المسارين
من الجهه الروسيه هناك العدد مقابل نوعيه
معينه من قبل الغرب اليوم هناك تحضير
العدد رفع مستوى الانتاج العسكري وبالتالي
اغراق الجبهه والتي هي بطول تقريبا 600
الى 800 كيلومتر اغراقها بالعديد من الجيش
الروسي وبالتالي جلب هذا المسيرات من من
هنا وهناك ولكن في المرحله المقبله يجب
على الغرب عندما وعد الغربي باعتاد من
الدبابات وغيرها هذه الدبابات لم تصل حتى
الان ولكن بالمرحله القادمه سلمى
الاحتمالان الاساسيان للحرب من جهه الرئيس
بوتين استرداد او السيطره على كل اقليم
الدومباز ويحتمل ان تقوم اوكرانيا بهجوم
ميزه فروجيا باتجاه الجنوب الى مليتو بول
لقطع الجسر البري هذه هي الاستعدادات بشكل
عام ومع عنوان المرحله المقبله في السنه
بدء السنه الثانيه
بدء السنه الثانيه يقال ان هناك تحذيرا
عسكريا كبيرا روسيا للاحتفال بمعركه مهمه
ولكن لا اعتقد ان هناك جوزيه معينه اليوم
الرئيس بوتين او الجيش الروسي يستبرق
الاستعدادات الاوكرانيه من قبل الغرب
لتثبيت مواقع معينه للمعركه الكبرى عميد
الياس حنام
حدثنا من بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك